>> Jesse Erickson:
So welcome everyone.
Thank you all for coming on
a pleasant D.C. afternoon
and during the holiday season.
I know it's a busy
time for us all.
It's sort of become a tradition
for the American Printing
History Association
to hold its annual lecture in
the location that the next,
next year's conference
will be held.
We hope to be able to make
an informal announcement
on that front soon.
But for now let us just
say that we can expect
that we'll be coming back
to the Chesapeake Bay area
for the conference in 2019.
I'd like to take a moment
to thank Mark [inaudible]
and the Library of
Congress staff
for hosting this year's
Lieberman Lecture.
I'd especially like to extend
my sincere appreciation
to Dr. Stephanie [inaudible]
for all the work she's done
to help make this
event possible.
Additionally I need to
thank President [inaudible]
and George Barnum
of the American Printing History
Associates National Board.
And also the Chesapeake
Bay Chapter.
For providing further support
in putting this all together.
The Annual Lieberman Lecture
commemorates J. Ben Lieberman,
founder and first president
of the American Printing
History Association.
And I'll just plug
my own institution.
His papers are actually held
at the University of Delaware
which I just found out
a couple of days ago.
[Laughter] So that's
really exciting.
I'm going to dig in,
into his history more.
We are extremely fortunate
to have Dr. Sarah Werner deliver
this year's Annual Lieberman,
Lieberman Lecture.
Dr. Werner is well
known among members
of the bibliophilic community.
I first became aware of
her work through her blog,
Wynken de Worde which
is really one
of the finest blogs of its kind.
And given that threads are
currently in vogue now.
But I'd have to say that
her Twitter account,
wynkenhimself is a
must-follow [laughter].
But [inaudible] her,
her content,
online content really speaks
to her erudition
and, and brilliance.
Dr. Werner is a book historian.
And a digital scholar based
here in Washington, D.C. area.
Usually describes
herself as an independent,
an independent librarian.
She taught Early
Modern Printing History
at the Folger Shakespeare
Library for nearly a decade.
And is the author of
Studying Early Printed Books:
1450 to 1800.
A practical guide, coming
out from Wylie this year.
Or this winter.
She's also the author
of Shakespeare
and Feminist Performance:
Ideology on stage.
And numerous articles on
theater practice, book history,
and digital practices.
Last year, she gave
the Pforzheimer Lecture
at the Harry Ransom Center on
"Early Digital Facsimiles."
And she's been a plenary
speaker at RBMS and part
of the Rare Book
School lecture series.
Her current project
is a technological
and cultural study
of facsimiles.
Her talk today, Working
Towards a Feminist History
of Printing fits right in
with the conference theme
for next year which is that
of Celebrating Diversity
in the History of
American Printing.
So without further
delay, please help me
in welcoming Dr. Sarah Werner.
[ Applause ]
>> Sarah Werner:
Hello, and thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
And I want to say thank you
to Jesse for the invitation.
And to the Chesapeake Chapter
and the Library of Congress
for making all of this possible.
I'm really looking forward
to this conversation.
I should warn you that kind
of like what my scholarly
career has been.
This is less of a
straight-forward here I am.
Here's my argument.
We're just going to shoot
down towards the end.
It's a following of
thoughts that we're going
to sort of explore together.
So I want to talk today
about what a feminist
history of printing could be.
And what we lose by thinking
of it primarily in terms
of the history of
women printing.
But first, I need to share some
context for these questions.
Let's see if I can do this.
Okay. A few years ago, I began
writing in earnest a guide
to how books were made
in the first centuries
of the printing press.
Studying early printed books,
the one that Jesse mentioned.
And there are fliers
on the back table.
I had been teaching bibliography
and early modern book culture
to undergraduates
for a decade by then.
And the whole time
I was teaching,
I struggled to find
a suitable text
to help them understand
the common press.
Some guides were
entirely too brief.
They would touch on imposition
and stop press changes.
And then that was it.
And then there was
Philip Gaskell
who wrote a wonderful book
full of details about printing.
So many details that
it is unfair
to call it an introduction
by today's 'standards.
For true beginners, the
book shares its knowledge
so authoritatively.
And densely that it's
hard to take hold of
and find a purchase on it.
You have to understand
the full run
of press work before you
can really appreciate the
significance of format,
for instance.
And yet there was no
helpful navigation system
to let you move around the
book as you might need.
I do love it, but.
And so you follow
Gaskell's lead.
And if you read it enough times,
or if you have a patient teacher
to guide you through it,
you might absorb
enough of its subject.
To return to it on
more equal footing.
So I set out to write what I
refer to as "Baby Gaskell,"
a beginners' level exploration
of how the hand press worked.
And why it might be
good to know that.
Another piece of context.
My classes were overwhelmingly
taken by women.
They looked kind
of like this row.
I don't know about your
classes, if you teach.
But I would wager that
like classes in the English
or Library Science or History,
indeed like many
Liberal Arts courses,
the student population
is more female than male.
Perhaps because of that and
perhaps because I am who I am.
Which is someone who is never
not thinking about gender.
Our seminar discussions
often turned to speculations
about gendered reading habits.
Or how print genders authorship.
And so as I was writing my
book, I started to worry
about how it was unthinkingly
replicating a gendered printing.
My first book was on Shakespeare
feminist performance.
Was I inadvertently
writing a book
that was printing in
[inaudible] press?
But since I was writing
about printing, not printers,
where were my opportunities
to intervene?
Mine wasn't a work about
books or about the book trade.
So there was to focus
on authors or printers
or booksellers per se.
Just a lot of information
about machines and processes
and discussions of
why it matters.
So how could I bring my
investment in feminists' theory
and practice to the
forefront of this work?
Twenty years ago, Leslie
Howsam published a brief
but pointed call to
arms in sharp news.
In my view women and book
history is her advocacy
for an explicitly
feminist approach
to studying book history.
But Howsam isn't interested in
excavating women's histories.
And she deliberately
sets that approach aside.
"Most of the women whose work
in the book's cycle has been
so painstakingly
discovered by researchers.
Has been, oop, has been
atypical individuals.
Outstanding anomalies
in a cultural field
dominated by men," she says.
I think she might be
overstating the assumption
that such women were
entirely atypical.
There's evidence that
in the first centuries
of the printing press.
Women were an integral part of
the daily work of bookmaking
and bookselling, if
in small numbers.
Although there's also evidence
that their numbers dropped
off in later centuries.
But her larger point I
think is still germane.
Adding to the scant
list of women known
to have been involved
in the book trades.
Only makes it slightly
less scant.
And such recovery work doesn't
necessarily help us confront.
The social and political forces
that shape women's lives.
There is, I sometimes find it
necessary to say, a difference
between women and book history.
And feminist approaches
to book history.
A catalogue of women
is not the same thing
as enabling a critical
examination
of the history of books.
Or the methodologies we've
used to study that history.
Returning to Leslie Howsam.
Instead of fleshing
out the list of women
in the book trades, she writes.
"I want to suggest that
book historians think
about how the book
has been implicated.
In those structures of
masculine power and authority.
Known to feminist
scholarship as patriarchy."
For her, in other
words, the possibilities
for feminist book history lie
in working not with women.
Necessarily, but with gender.
The questions to ask are
not who made these books?
But how are books
conceived of as gendered?
As an illustration of this
avenue of investigation.
Howsam points to the language
of conquest and courting used
by collectors as one
potential avenue.
Such as this from
Richard Corell in 1930.
"Books without points are
like women without beauty.
They pass unnoticed
in the crowd.
But books with points
excite immediate interest
in everybody, so to speak.
Turns to gaze at them."
As Howsam suggests in response,
"Perhaps we can also think
about the gendered possessive
not altogether unsexualized way
that book collectors have fixed
their gaze upon the object
of desire."
Some of you might want to
pat yourselves on the back,
thinking that 1930
was a long time ago.
But his attitude still shows
up in catalogues today.
Rebecca Romney has
been compiling examples
like this one.
"perfect companion to curls.
Prettier copies are out there.
And even though I live in L.A.,
or maybe because I live in L.A.,
I'll take the girl
with depth of soul.
Over the ubiquitous,
superficially attractive ones."
And that's from a catalogue-- .
Yeah, exactly.
Just from a catalogue just
a couple of years ago.
And this isn't the only one
that shows how much the
male gaze is so with us.
Rebecca has a whole
file of them.
I'm really grateful to her for
sharing some examples with me.
And if you happen to
come across examples
of these things in your work.
I'm sure Rebecca would really
love to know about them.
So. The tool Howsam uses
to outside this gaze is
Jane Marcus' Theorization
of Feminist Aesthetics.
As Marcus works through it,
a feminist aesthetic is one
that values process
over product.
One that avoids hierarchies
and exclusions.
For Howsam, this suggests a
feminist praxis of book study
that downplays possession
in favor of utility.
Instead of favoring first
editions and famous authors,
it might instead think in
terms of less visible books.
That gain meaning through
their social circulation.
Perhaps, she suggests,
wryly, the way large numbers
of readers, both men and
women make use of books.
Maybe just as interesting in
the ways in which small numbers
of authors, publishers,
and collectors work
together to create fashion.
And preserve books.
Howsam's desire to focus on the
utility and social circulation
of books aligns closely
with my own practice
and preference of
studying books.
One that tends to focus on
things like [inaudible].
Very popular multi-lingual
phrase books
and dictionaries
published across Europe.
In editions too many to count.
And many of you will
already know this about me.
To express frustration
is what I do with things
like the obsessive tracking
of Shakespeare's first folio.
And the [inaudible]
goes, "Oh, my gosh, yes."
[Laughter] It's not a
novel approach to the study
of books, by any means.
Although it's still not
something that is often put
through an explicitly
feminist lens.
But I want to look
a bit more closely
at how Howsam incorporates
Marcus' theory
of feminist aesthetics
into her own speculations.
Much of the work Howsam
does draws on this excerpt
from Marcus' 1988 book, Art and
Anger: Reading Like a Woman.
"This model of art," Howsam
quotes, "with repetition
and dailiness at
the heart of it.
With the teaching of
other women the patient
of one's cultural heritage
as the object of it.
Is a female poetic which
women live and accept.
Transformation rather
than permanence is
at the heart of this aesthetic.
As it is at the heart
of most women's lives.
History is preserved not in the
art object, but in the tradition
of making the art object."
It's this account of daily
making that leads Howsam
to the observation that feminist
book history could attend
to how books are used and
attend to books that are part
of the everyday and ordinary.
What catches my attention
however is how much this
scenario reminds me of
the act of printing.
The repetition and
dailiness and patience
of working the printing press.
And setting the type.
This is the unavoidable
nature of the actions
without which printing
wouldn't happen.
And Marcus' emphasis on making
the art object resonates
strongly for me with
analytical bibliography.
Especially as I've spent
the last years writing
about how books are made.
And teaching students how
to recover that process
through the physical evidence
left behind in material texts.
So where does Marcus get
this model of art from?
Here's the full passage
taken from Still Practice:
A rested Alphabet Toward
a Feminist Aesthetic.
The 1984 article that is one
of the three pieces forming
the basis of her book.
As an aside, I should note
that throughout this talk,
I tend to quote from articles
that books were based on.
Largely because as an
independent scholar,
articles are a lot easier
for me to access than books
and that I think
is also something.
That's part of thinking
about what a feminist
history might be.
Lipking, you would
know, in this quote,
refers to Lawrence Lipking's
piece Aristotle's Sister.
In which he argues for a
feminine poetics of abandonment.
An important foil for Marcus in
this I know, lengthy, passage.
"We could imagine another
aesthetic, call it Penelope's,
which grew out of
a female culture.
Lipking says that
Arimneste, Aristotle's sister,
'cannot compete, of course,
with her brother's tradition.'
Penelope's aesthetic
does not wish to compete.
This anti-hierarchical,
anti-theoretical,
not aggressively exclusionary.
A real woman's poetics is
a poetics of commitment.
Not the poetics of abandonment."
Above all, it does not separate
art from work in daily life.
Penelope weaves her
tapestry by day.
And takes it apart by night.
Could Aristotle destroy
his lectures
and start over again each day?
This model of art
with repetition
and dailiness at
the heart of it.
With the teaching of other
women the patient craft
of one's cultural heritage.
As the object of it
is a female poetic
which women live and accept.
Penelope's art is work.
As women cook food
that is eaten.
Weave cloth that is worn.
Clean houses that are dirtied.
Transformation rather than
permanence is at the heart
of this aesthetic as
it is at the heart
of most women's lives."
The ellipses in Howsam,
all the bits of the weaving
that she has unpicked from
this argument are all the parts
that are about Penelope.
I can see why she would
worry in her brief piece
that it would be a distraction.
That it would take
too much explanation
to give it proper context.
But that this passage is
about Penelope undoing her
weaving every night makes it
for me all the more
about printing.
As an aesthetic about printing,
Marcus' account here
works shockingly well,
even better than
with the emissions.
If you've ever done even
the smallest bit of work
on common presses, you know
that it is entirely a process.
Not only of repetition, but of
breaking down and starting over.
Dab ink on the balls, work
the ink, dabbing on the form.
Dab, work, work, dab.
And at the end of the say, take
the stuffing out of the balls.
Soak the leather
and next morning,
reassemble and start again.
Pick the piece of type up.
Place it in the stick.
Place another, place another,
put the line on the stone.
Put another, put
another, tie it up.
Tie up another page.
Tie up another.
Lock it up, print it off,
distribute the type
back into its boxes.
Start all over again.
Place the paper on the tin
pan, fold the frisket down.
Fold the whole thing down.
Roll it under the [inaudible]
and pull the bar [inaudible].
And once more, pull again.
Roll it out.
Open the frisket,
take the paper off.
Put the paper on.
Fold it down, fold it down,
roll, pull, roll, pull.
Roll, pull, open,
hang the paper.
Go home. Come back the next
morning and do it all again.
Penelope's weaving
disappears each night.
And a printer's work does not.
Since the printed paper
remains and heats in gatherings.
But the unmaking of the press's
parts are a key components
to keeping the work going
and the debtors at bay.
And if you are as I am,
committed to the belief
that every single copy
of a text is unique,
thanks to inevitable
printing variance.
And the vagaries of
its individual life.
Then an awareness of repetition
and variation makes
an aesthetic based
on Penelope's weaving
all the more compelling.
So let's talk about actual hand
press printing for a moment.
If I'm only interested in
the mechanics of printing
as the only thing
really my book was about.
Need I think about
gender at all?
Well, yes.
Always yes.
But especially yes in
Renaissance England.
Where the word press was term
that could be used both to refer
to printing but also
to a physical pressing
of a man into a woman.
That is an act of sexual
penetration and deflowering.
The author might
be a man in print,
but he is not pressed
as a lady is pressed.
It is the book that is
pressed, and the author
who does the pressing.
An ambiguity, an anxiety
that Wendy Wall works
with in her 1993 book,
The Imprint of Gender.
But there need not be
winks and nudges for sex
to be brought into the topic.
Lisa Maruca's 1993 Bodies
of Type is the rare piece
of scholarship that
reads printers manuals.
Not as transparent
printing lessons.
But for their rhetorical
and ideological practices.
In her hands, we are
brought to see the gendered
and sexualized language
that is repeatedly drawn
on in these manuals.
Take for instance this passage
from Joseph Moxon's
1683 Mechanic Exercises
on the Whole Art of Printing.
In which he describes
the component parts
of a letter mold.
"When his stick of
letters is thus transferred
to the male block,
he claps the middle
of the male block
into his left hand.
Tilting the feet of the
letter a little upwards
so that the face might
rest upon the tongue.
And then takes about the middle
of the female block
in his right hand.
And lays it so upon the
male block that the tongue
of the male block may fall into
the tongue of the female block.
[Laughter] So that when the knot
of the male block is lightly
drawn towards the knot
of the female block.
Or the knot of the female block
lightly thrusts toward the knot
of the male block.
Both knots shall squeeze the
letter close between them."
We are so habituated to
the description of plugs
and other objects being
described as female or male.
That it might not occur to
you to note this passage
when reading through Moxon.
I don't think I did until I
started reading Lisa's work.
And of course, the language
of the human body
is used throughout.
Pieces of type have feet,
shoulders, heads, bodies.
But Maruca points out that such
language emerges in this period.
The OED traces the use of
male and female as adjectives
for objects with
projecting of hollow ends.
To the late 16th century.
The first entry for male gauges
is Moxon's passage earlier
in this section about
male gauges falling
into female gauges.
These are not just bodies, but
bodies that are being sexed.
And John Smith, 1755,
The Printer's Grammar.
The laboring bodies
have disappeared
as Maruca points out.
But a rigid gender
hierarchy remains
to govern appropriate
typeface choices.
The strong upright Roman face
should be used for the main text
with a delicate flowing
italic, used only to decorate
within the Roman context.
Maruca's project in the
work of print, the 2007 book
into which her article
is incorporated is
to consider the many ways
in which the acts and agents
of bookmaking create an
ideology of authorship
that is gendered
and politicized.
But what I want to
call attention
to is how effectively she puts
down the wishful thinking.
That we can treat printer's
manuals as transparent windows
onto early modern
acts of printing.
So much of what we know
about how books were made
in the hand-pressed period.
Are based on Moxon and Smith.
And the [inaudible].
Bibliographers draw on their
work to produce the works
that become the basis
of our study.
Works like those of
McCarrow and Gaskell.
How do we escape the masculinist
underpinnings of our knowledge?
Is it useful here to think
about Dianna Taylor's notions
of archive and repertoire?
To deal with the tensions
between reading ideological
texts and the desire
to recover acts of printing?
Taylor's concepts fleshed out
in her 2003 book are based
in performance studies.
And geared towards
recovering Latin American
cultural histories.
And while I sometimes get
impatient with her dichotomy.
I also find it generative.
Here's a quick and superficial
description of her concepts.
Cultural memory is contained
both in written archives
and in bodily repertoire.
When the dominant history of
conquest has been preserved
in archival documents.
Where can you find
indigenous culture
in history in its own voice?
In the embodied history
of experience passed
down from one generation of
survivors to the next, she says.
Theater, dance, gesture, all
can be valid forms of knowledge
and history and capture what
written documents cannot.
So if printers' manuals are part
of the written archive
of printing history.
And if they have an
ideological slant.
As Maruca's readings says
they do and as all things do.
Can we counter that bias in the
physical repertoire of printing?
Is a feminist praxis
of printing history one
that emphasizes doing
over reading?
Although printing practices
have changed over the centuries,
scholar/printers have
long been interested
in early techniques
of bookmaking.
Debating finer points.
Rebuilding presses.
And relearning what
was once known.
There might not be an embodied
repertoire that's been handed
down to us in a direct line
from London's printers
in the 17th century.
But there is an active
repertoire living in bodies,
printing on wooden
hand presses today.
Bodies or people who are often
eager to share what they know.
It isn't only muscle memory
involved in being able
to pull the bar, lower the
[inaudible] just smoothly
and hard enough.
But a physical knowledge
that is expressed
by doing rather than writing.
And that repertoire of
knowledge through doing.
Is a central part of exploring
how hand press printing worked.
On the other hand.
And this is no small
point when we're thinking
about equity and inclusion.
Books can be significantly
more accessible
than bodies and printing
presses.
There are only so many
printers and so many presses.
Printers deserve to be
paid for their time.
Replica presses are much
too heavy to travel.
How many educators work
at a place where printing
on a common press can
easily be incorporated
into your classroom practice?
How many educators are active
printers or have access to funds
to pay printers a decent fee
for working with their students?
But books can be
priced affordably.
I know they are not
always, but they can be.
They can be resold
for even less.
They could often
exist in digital form.
Maybe accessible to a wide range
of abled and disabled users.
You can take them home and
revisit them on your own time
if you didn't understand what
happened in the classroom.
And you can keep them until
you've used them to pieces.
Not that any of us would be
so careless with our books.
There are good reasons why we
teach history from the archive
and not through repertoire.
And among them the
documents are more conducive
to how universities are set up.
And we should never forget
the material conditions
that inform what we do.
If we're historians and
bibliographers in fact.
Our training should mean that
we always keep those material
conditions at the
forefront of our thoughts.
Let's go back to
where this started.
What is a Feminist
History of Printing?
And what do we lose by
thinking of it primarily
as the history of
women printing?
I've had to think about my
own feminist praxis outside
of recovering women's history.
Because of my recent focus
on explicating the workings
of presses and libraries.
But maybe that's
only my problem.
Why not look in the
archives to recover
who the early women
printing in France were?
Why not compile a
catalogue of books printed
by women in early America?
How is that not a feminist
practice of book history?
It can be.
I can think of plenty of
works of printing history
that I would say are
doing feminist work.
And I can absolutely
think of works
about equivalent
modern technologies.
Like Marie Hick's recent
Programmed Inequality
that are field changing and
profoundly feminist ways.
And that are consistent with
this sort of work that we do
in the history of printing.
So I'm not saying that
such work isn't valuable.
But it can't be the
only feminist work
that print historians are doing.
Let's talk about recovery
history for a moment.
Why we do it and
what we're missing.
Today's drive to
recover the history
of women's activities
comes primarily
out of the feminist
movement of the early 1970s.
We need to tell her story, not
his-story, urged Robin Morgan.
And it's no coincidence that
the word her story first appears
in print as part of the byline
for Morgan's [inaudible]
Good-bye to All That.
The editorial she published
in the January 1970 issue
or Rat Subterranean News.
Which was taken over
by women in protest
of the male editorial
staff misogyny.
If Morgan was a woman
inspired to commit "herstory,"
as she signed herself.
Her readers were ready for it.
Ready to stop believing the
stories they'd been told
about what was good
behavior and what was bad.
What counted and what didn't.
Let it all hang out,
Let it seem bitchy,
catty, dike-y, [inaudible].
Frustrated, crazy, nutty,
frigid, ridiculous, bitter,
embarrassing, man-hating,
libelist, pure, unfair, envious,
intuitive, low-down,
stupid, petty, liberating.
We are the women that
men have warned up about.
[Laughter]
That drive to look back
at the stories we've been
told and to see the gaps.
Where we've been
removed is powerful.
Honest to god, every
time I read through that.
I get the, I get
the shivers, right?
We were all these, all along.
That witch in the corner
of your eye is the widow
who won't marry.
That scandalous behavior is
running a profitable business
on her own.
We are the women that
men have warned us about.
And we have always
been part of history.
It's powerful to feel that
rush of connection to the past.
Recovering the history of women
printing does that for us.
And what about the history
of enslaved women
in the book trades?
Or the history of indigenous
people and the printing press?
Where's the queer
history of printing?
The trans history?
You tell me you've
recovered the history
of a previously hidden
group in the book trades.
And I will ask you
about another group.
Where are they and what's
the connection between them?
If we are recovering history
in order to make it all
of our history, we are
faced with the choice
between either ignoring who
is excluded from that all.
Or searching for
more and more firsts.
And more and more histories to
make the past more equitable.
But you cannot simply keep
adding recovered histories
and think that it will
take care of the problems.
Of our overwhelmingly white
male field faces today.
It's an odd thing, isn't it?
That I started off by talking
about how largely
female my classroom.
Yet here we are nearing
the end, and I'm talking
about how male the field is?
But in this book history
follows the pyramid of academia.
And libraries and book dealing.
In which there are large
numbers of women studying.
And working at the
lower levels of a field.
But the higher the status of the
job, the fewer women there are.
How does recovering history
level today's playing field?
Here's another question
to think about.
What do you want the future of
printing history to look like?
Who do you want to be printing?
Who do you want to
be studying it?
Who are writing the stories?
What sort of technology
is part of this process?
When I suggested our field
is facing problems today
because it is white and male.
What I want to focus on
is how much knowledge
and experience we are missing.
And how unsustainable
this pattern is.
Think about Dorothy
Porter at Howard University
and how she saw what the white
librarians in her era did not.
That the Dewey classification
system collapsed any possibility
of blacks being seen
through the lens.
Wait, classes the
possibility of them being said,
seen outside the frame of
either slavery or colonization.
[Inaudible] What about
Paula McDowell's revelations
about women's participation
in public print
and debate in the 18th century?
How could we even begin to
think about book history
as a discipline without
Elizabeth Eisenstein?
Our world would be immeasurably
poorer without them.
But when I look at my shelves of
books about hand press printing.
They are overwhelmingly
authored by men.
When I look at the
companions and readers we used
to teach book history.
The sections that touch
on technologies,
those about printing.
And those about digital books
are overwhelmingly authored
by men.
When I look at my own citation
practice in my own book.
A book in which I was
consciously trying not
to repeat this bias.
They are overwhelmingly male.
This is the part where I
shame myself thoroughly
and profoundly.
I was really horrified
when I counted.
I realized, look at those cards.
The future of printing
isn't going to be books
on wooden presses written
by and about white dudes.
The future of printing
and the future
of printing history is going
to be machines and computers
and technologies that
haven't been invented yet.
And they'll be used to make
texts and to circulate them
and to circulate the texts.
That are about the
making of the texts.
And they're going to
need to be written
by a much broader
range of people.
If our field is going to not
only be relevant and exciting.
But if it is going to exist.
Bibliographers are a
small group of scholars,
heavily indebted to the past.
The past when women could barely
squeeze through the entrance
into [inaudible]
and Bowers' classes.
And I really wish Barbara Mower
were here to tell us about that.
And it's a past of male
scholars and female typists
that still determines how we
understand and describe books.
So why do we need a feminist
praxis of printing history?
We need it so we can thrive.
We need it to expose
why we do what we do.
And to invite more people in to
help us understand the field.
Let's turn back one
more time to weaving.
What does thinking about
weaving get us in striving
for a feminist praxis?
The key part of the
Penelope story is not simply
that she weaves.
But that she takes apart
her weaving every night
and then starts again
the next morning.
It's the willingness to
dismantle paradoxically.
That makes her art an aesthetic
of commitment and
not abandonment.
Abandonment would
be walking away.
Commitment is sticking it out.
The problems, the errors, the
suitors who try to control you.
You fix the turned
letters, the dropped lines,
the last minute insertions.
Commitment is also dealing with
the harassment of the suitors
and we call them suitors.
But let's make no mistake,
they aren't courting her.
They're courting
Odysseus'' wealth.
Penelope is using the
strategy at her disposal
to delay an impossible situation
until she can assert
her own will.
Weaving is an art and
an everyday activity,
but it is also a protest.
A scholarly practice
based on weaving means not
that we erase our writing.
You know, which we already do.
It means that we keep our minds
open up to error and revision.
That we lead with a willingness
to relearn what we
thought we knew.
That we decenter
ourselves as experts.
And situate ourselves in a
community of questioners.
And it means too that
we make ourselves
and our knowledge accessible.
Are we publishing in
locked away spaces?
Or are we participating in the
open commons of conversation?
Are we willing to learn
and respond to changes
in the world around us?
If we insist that printing
history is one thing only.
That bibliography
is one thing only.
That a book is words on paper,
we are locking ourselves
out of the conversation.
Remember too that weaving
is grounded in the ordinary.
We are all at this moment
wearing something woven
or knitted or produced
through another textile form.
I'm hoping there might be people
who might actually be
knitting right now.
[Laughter] There is nothing
to be ashamed up in writing
in straight forward language
in unpopular platforms
that invite in people.
From outside our field.
The everyday can be
powerful and compelling.
For all of my fears
about whether,
I'm not sure I have
that slide yet.
For all of my fears
about whether my book was
reproducing a masculine
printing history.
I think I was worried
about the wrong thing.
It's not the subject of
my book that is the key.
But it's methodology.
My feminist praxis
lies in opening
up the gates to a
field of study.
In making complicated
abstract ideas understandable
and compelling, in
inviting those
who have been outside the field.
To move into its center.
And unraveling and
remaking the warp
and weft of my own knowledge.
I'm so grateful to you
all for this opportunity
to rethink my own
scholarly practices.
I hope this process of working
through what a feminist praxis
of print history
might look like.
Leads us all to think
about how we share
and open our field Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> So we have some time
for questions and answers.
So I will open up the
floor to questions.
>> I can't promise answers.
I said I would take questions.
I didn't promise-- I'll try for
answers, if anybody had any.
>> Well, I have sort of a
comment question [inaudible].
Alright? But I just was thinking
so much about all the threads
that you're weaving
for us today.
And thinking about the
book and printed word.
And how those are reproduced.
And how even today we are
continue to reproduce even
in new fields or research.
Certain areas of
digital [inaudible].
So I'm wondering if you had
a couple of thoughts on that.
And, and sort of ways of
pushing against some of that,
the embodiment of book history.
As it's reproduced and
reanalyzed in new ways?
So [inaudible].
>> So you know it's, it's.
I'm never quite sure
what to do with books
and digital humanities.
[Laughter] Right?
And the other handful of
people I know who are in that,
you know interlocking space.
Because on the one
hand there is a large
and important body
of work being done.
On texts in digital humanities.
In which you, you
know, you OCR on text.
And you strip it out.
Then you do all sorts
of fun stuff
with it and it's important.
And not my thing.
But there is lots of interesting
work that can be done there.
So on the one hand, the,
the body of the book drops
out altogether, right?
And there's a, another
group of people
who are very book-focused.
Who are interested in digital
tools, but are very skeptical
of digital tools being
able to reproduce
or make available the
physical materiality of books.
And I love, I love
digitization of books, right?
Like this is, this is my thing.
I get lost in looking
at, at them.
All the time.
I think that we are just,
we are so in the baby years
of this sort of technology.
And you know honestly, what
do most people do with books?
They read them.
I mean, like I can't like, I
can't fault people who think
that like books are words.
Right? Like probably up until
about a decade ago, I would,
just thought of books as words.
I wasn't thinking of all
the stuff that went into it.
So I'm not super
happy at the moment
that there is this
weird tension.
Between like the body
of the book is important
and can't be digital.
And text is always
inherently digital.
Like obviously if
you're a bibliographer,
you know, duh, no.
You can't separate the
text from the book.
And we haven't yet in
digital [inaudible] I think
with the exception of a
small group of people.
Really started to push at that
and, and think about that.
I hope that answers the.
I don't what to do with
gendering about that.
Although there is gendering
to do with about that.
In part because the,
because now is the, the text,
the text world is
heavily dominated by men.
I'm looking at Jen to be like,
"How should I phrase this?"
The text mining version of it
is heavily, it's heavily male.
And it's male in ways that
often discourage women
from participating in the field.
So it's often exclusionarily
male.
I don't know if exclusionarily
is a word.
But so there's something
going on in there, too.
Jenn?
>> How does the book
arts community sort
of fit within that?
>> I don't know.
I don't know.
And I really, I don't, I don't.
I was thinking about
the book arts community
when I was doing this.
Because I wanted to find
interesting examples.
And then I just sort of
said, "You know what?
Like I really-- I'm already.
I'm already mucking around
in stuff that I don't know."
Like I really don't know
the book arts community.
And it's so rich.
And it's so important.
And there's so much
happening there.
That I was like I have
to come back to that.
Later. I, I, you know it's.
I have so many "next
books" at this point.
I have a slight suspicion
that that community might
be more female than male?
How do I think--
is that, is that,
is that seem like
an accurate-- ?
And there is again
something about.
I think going back to the ways
in which Leslie Howsam was.
Like think about how
the book is gendered.
I don't know.
It, and, and stuff
that Wendy Wall does.
I keep coming back to this
sense that the perception is
that authorship is
gendered male.
But books are gendered female.
Is the whole pressing thing and
I didn't talk about the emblems
from [inaudible] that I dropped
in here in a couple of times.
You know it's a book of emblems.
So you get an emblems, and they
get a little thing about, oh!
Printing. And you get
this woman who appears.
From the early, when printing
first start to appear,
there's that woodcut
that was at the beginning
of the talk of the woman.
And then she keeps reappearing
and she gets turned into.
Then it's a horrible
picture, isn't it?
Like it's, she looks
like she's in pain.
And I don't know what--
her head's sort of
falling off her head.
Like it's just.
But it makes so much sense to
me that she's, she's a woman.
Because it's all
about the press.
And it's all about
the materiality.
It's all about being, going back
to that being pressed thing.
[Inaudible]
>> Thanks, Sarah,
that was amazing.
>> Thank you.
>> And incredibly timely
too at least for me.
I was listening before
coming into the building.
I was messaging with a friend.
And I was using [inaudible]
function on my phone
to say over and over again.
People can be famous for
things besides being first.
[Laughter] People can be famous
for things besides being first
and that's occasioned
by a, a recent death.
The passing of a very remarkable
woman named [inaudible].
Who has been widely and
somewhat incorrectly imported
as having invented
the word processor.
And she had an amazing career.
She did lots of things
that are worthy
of memory and celebration.
Literally inventing the word
processor was not quite one
of them.
And so just this
sort of conundrum.
Of how do we frame histories,
especially when they're sort
of moved into the
popular sphere.
When we're talking about
New York Times headlines
and that sort of thing?
Obituaries in the
New York Times.
How do you sort of find
ways to frame histories
that are not about [inaudible].
About being first?
And if you know I mean I
think obviously that's sort
of something that
you're addressing.
But I'm wondering if you have
any thoughts in particular
on why we're so obsessed
with firsts
in various technological
histories.
>> I don't know, but you know.
It's not only technological
histories.
I think about like what was
the first sonnet sequence?
And who was the first
woman writer to imprint?
And who was I mean
all of the, there's.
We, I don't know why.
Apparently we must be wired.
I mean like human brains
have some sort of way
to say like it's a race.
First is, first is the best.
But first is so deeply,
so deeply problematic.
Because I don't know.
Second is just as
interesting as first.
And 500th is just as
important as first.
And then when you talk
about printing back in,
I almost called it, "my day."
Printing back in my day, as
if I'm like 500 years old.
We don't-- .
>> You look good.
[Laughter]
>> I really, I try, you know?
It's there are so
many lost records.
And one of the big
problems with studying,
recovering women's printing
history in the Renaissance.
Is that there's all
these anonymous printers.
Like we don't know who they are.
They have initials.
Or there's, they continue
publishing, widows.
They continue publishing
under their husband's name.
Like how do you actually
find them?
And then if you start
getting into sort
of other archival histories.
Dispossessed Lives is
written by-- [inaudible].
Yes, Marissa Fuentes.
Yes, I mean so you get into
other interesting questions
about how do archival documents.
Represent histories
that aren't-- .
It's like what I was saying
about the indigenous stuff.
You know, histories that
can't speak for themselves
because they have been silenced
by whoever's creating
the document.
All of those get in
the way of firsts.
I, I'm, I don't know, I'm not
really interested in firsts.
And one of the big problems
is like the New York Times.
I feel like they're saying
is like, if you think ahead
to like next generation
scholars.
If it wasn't for the work
that like you've done.
Or work like Marie
Hicks has been doing.
We can see like somebody has
taken the time at the moment.
To sort of excavate is the
word that's coming to mind.
To take apart the New
York Times obit and say.
Here are the biases in there.
The New York Times
always talks about the,
those future historians, right?
They would do what I do.
Which is you look up the wills.
You look up the probate records.
I mean, they do the
equivalent of that.
And they go, "oh, look!
She invented the-- ."
That's not-- .
[ Inaudible ]
I am actually the oldest child
so I'm not sure I believe that.
But. [Laughter] My sister
would, would be happy.
To me, you're kind of
describing the moment in fall
when you know the
trees are prettiest.
Not the first leaf
that's beautiful,
but there's a moment
when [inaudible].
And I'm wondering when
people look back at our time.
Will they see a moment
[inaudible]?
Or are we just [inaudible]?
>> I, I-- .
[ Inaudible ]
No, you know it.
That's a super good question.
I don't have an answer.
And all I can say is
I had a conversation
with Fletcher [inaudible]
recently about binding in this.
And he was on a, if
you know Fletcher.
If any of you Fletcher, you
can follow him on Twitter.
He's actually also
lovely on Twitter.
He gets a bee in his bonnet,
and then he just goes off at it.
And he's a conservator.
He's like this is a world
I don't' really know.
So I learn a lot from him.
I don't always agree with him.
But like we were talking about
the tendency for books today,
when they have to be rebound.
If it's a book from,
you know 1300.
That oftentimes conservation
will want to re bind it
in a style that emulates that
is appropriate to that period.
And I was like well yeah, duh.
What else would you do?
Right? Like this is, we are
so used to thinking about it.
And he was like think
about what is,
like where's the
21st century binding?
Like where, where is our art?
Where have we lost that?
Because we were so interested
in only recreating that.
And I don't know.
Really it's not 21st
century books.
But why can't it be
like we value those 19th
century bindings.
But we're not taking,
we're not stripping.
I know value's not necessarily
the right word because some
of them are really hideous.
And there are so many of
those red and gold things.
And we don't strip them off.
I want to sort of look around
like what have we got here?
[Laughter] We've got a lot of
this with the library bindings.
[Inaudible] Yeah, yeah.
But there's a, I mean,
just, just this sort of-- .
I just don't like well, I don't
know what I would do with this
in 21st century and
21st century books.
But the pause, what he did was
he opened up this moment for me
that I hadn't thought about.
And I love it when, when
people can do that for me.
And that was one of the things
I was struggling with newspaper.
Looking at something
totally differently
than how I look at it.
And seeing what comes out of it.
And sometimes what comes
out of it is like, "Yep!
I was right."
And sometimes what comes
out of it is like, "Oh.
I need to go back and
revisit everything I did
because my [inaudible]
cards are embarrassing."
But that was not
really an answer.
But it's a really good question.
>> That was great.
It's going forward,
and I appreciate that.
>> Mark, and then I
don't know your name.
I'm sorry.
>> This is a great talk.
>> Thank you.
>> Thought-provoking
and I really appreciate
your discussions struggling
when you're trying to teach
to incorporate aspects
of this beyond the,
the object moment made.
And then going on
to something else.
Although it is very
hard at times.
But one of the things I find
myself maybe sloppily dumping
into is women as market.
Which seems to bring in more
of a broader interpretation.
And it's really a
19th century subject.
And we can do, we can talk only
about women for quite a while
in terms of what's [inaudible]
and what it appeals to and.
Do you have thoughts about that?
>> I think that, I'm
thinking about women as users
of books is very
compelling and very,
and potentially really powerful.
In part because it gets at,
it gets at questions
of anonymity again.
And it can certainly
turn upside down.
If people always want to believe
that any marketing book was
written by a famous person.
Because I used to do this
assignment with my students.
There's like you know
you had to study books',
books' usage through history.
As they would look
at inscriptions.
And you're like.
And I would just be like
is it possible to figure
out who you know Jay
Doolittle is on it?
I don't know.
Sort of like E. Dickinson.
And they were like, "Wow,
this is Emily Dickinson."
No, weirdly there are a lot
of other E. Dickinsons
in the world."
[Laughter] Than that one.
But the ways in which
so it, it sort of.
I do think that it can
start to get at lives
that we don't necessarily see
when we're only looking
at the firsts.
And the select fews.
And I also opens up
categories of books
that we might not otherwise
be focusing on, right?
So we'll see books,
recipe books.
Those are huge focus right now.
Those are really interesting.
And if we were still
only focused
on the high literary
canon, we'd be missing
that whole body of,
of knowledge.
And it's, it's fun.
And that's part of
the direction that,
that Howsam goes
in in her piece.
From 20 years ago.
Which I still find sort
of shocking how relevant
it is, right?
Right now still.
You have a?
>> My question is kind of big.
But I wanted to bring it
back around to teaching.
And how we can inflect these
kinds of feminist practices
into the classroom, you know.
And we introduce these
ideas to [inaudible].
And I was just curious about
your essential thoughts
on implementing this
kind of approach
to book history with students.
>> So one of the,
one of the things
that happened is I started
asking these questions.
I was like, "Oh, I actually kind
of have been teaching like this.
So maybe that's it was
sort of reassuring to me."
Part of the context is this
course that I was teaching
on book history drew students
from different universities.
So it was based at the Folger,
and there's no college
associated locally
with the Folger.
So they come in from
different places.
And they came in from
different fields.
Like some of them would be
like, "I'm majoring in German."
And it'd be like,
"I'm a biology major."
And, "I'm a classics major."
And then I would set them loose
and have them choose books.
And if you're 21 years
old and you've never been
in a rare books library.
How, like what's
interesting to you?
We have random stuff!
Like some of them would be like,
"I've been reading
the Fairy Queen.
So now I'm going to work
on this early edition
of the Fairy Queen."
I'd go, "Oh, god, okay."
It's a great poem, but
the book's like, you know,
that's a lot of pages.
[Laughter] And other ones
would be like, "Here,
I pulled up this weird
treatise about math that's half
in Latin and half in English."
And I'd be like,
"I don't know what
that is and that's awesome!"
People would pull up almanacs.
And so my, my point is
that for a lot of the books
that they chose that they wanted
to work on, I didn't know.
I could not be the center of
knowledge in that classroom.
What I could be is the
person who opens up the door.
And says, "Here's
questions to ask.
Here are places to go.
Here are people who might
have the answers about this.
Here's how you can find
out what you're doing."
What is important to
know when you teach
like that is it's terrifying.
Right? If you've been
trained to be the professor
at the front of the classroom.
You have been taught
in graduate school
that you are supposed
to be the expert.
Right? And you walk in, you're
like, "I know everything.
You are just going to sit there
and you're going
to listen to me."
And even if you've been
taught to sort of like,
"I'm going to run a seminar."
It's totally a fake seminar.
In which you are guiding
the discussion, to an answer
that you already know that
you want them to believe.
And this is a situation
where you can't do that.
And they will ask.
They would ask me
questions in class.
I'd be like, I'm
sorry, I don't know!
We're going to have to look at
that and come back next week.
And talk about it again
because I just-- .
And that's, I love it.
But it's, it's hard
to, it's hard to do.
It's really, it's
super regarding.
It's super rewarding.
It's way more fun because
what's the, what's the fun
in like getting people
to get to the answer
that you already know?
I think like after, you
know, after ten years,
it can be sort of boring.
But there's all these
moments when they come
up with something unexpected.
And you go, "Oh!
I never thought of
Tempest that way!"
But to, but to let them grow
as learners in front of you.
And to teach you a new
things, super cool!
>> So I read somewhere when Ruth
Bader Ginsburg was asked what
would be the optimum number
of women on the Supreme Court,
she said, of course nine.
So I wanted to hear
a little bit more
about your thing
about the hierarchy.
And that most women
are at the bottom.
Which I agree.
The more women study
but fewer people are
in positions of responsibility.
But do you see any change in
that in the last 25 years?
Or?
>> I have not tracked it.
It's funny, just on the
Metro ride coming in,
Lady Science is the
name of the-- .
I don't know if you
guys know this.
Is the name of a,
it's like a blog.
It's an online magazine.
And they're really focused
on sort of like questions
about like science and gender.
But they're having a
series at the moment
about libraries and gender.
So they had just done
a post today sort
of about salary discreption
in libraries.
And they're saying it's not,
it's not about the,
it is still there.
It doesn't seem to have
really gotten better.
In the last 20 years in that
it's, it's not about tech.
It's not just because
it's like men do the tech
and there are all these new
tech jobs in the library.
That's why there's
a discrepancy.
The author's conclusion
was it's baked
into the hierarchy of libraries.
It's a, I was like I
can't remember more.
I don't know, google Lady
Science, maybe it'll come up?
It was not a good
reference librarian moment.
I just did right there.
Jenn just found it, yes!
The Pink Collar Library,
technology
and the gender wage gap.
From yes. December
13, that's today.
They just published it today.
I, I did not hallucinate.
Jenn is the master of finding
links while you are talking.
>> I really just
googled [inaudible].
>> Oh, so it worked!
That was a good reference
librarian moment!
So google it.
But it was interesting to think
about, especially in terms
of sort of like how-- that
question of how many is enough.
I just think to start with
that question is always going
to be limiting the
number of whoever it is
that we're talking about.
>> I think, I think Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's point was is
that it was accepted it would be
nine men for you know 200 years.
Why wouldn't we accept it
because it could be nine women?
>> Right. And part of the,
and then that, that has right,
like that's another
profession which is.
There are way more women in
law school than there are men.
And that's been true
for a while now.
Like it's, it's really turning
into, at least the student body.
It's sort of like female.
But look who our
partners is at law firms.
Not that law firms are
necessarily the be-all
and end-all of of life.
It's a structural problem
in lots of, lots of places.
But the, that pink collar,
the lady science
article's interesting
for libraries to think about.
What is it that we're doing?
We're so well-intentioned.
How is it that library
conferences
and book history conferences
keep having conversations
about diversity?
How can we recognize that we
are not a very diverse field?
How can we get to
be more diverse?
We keep having the conversations
over and over and over again.
And yet look.
The numbers aren't shifting.
Last year RBMS.
Last, last year our,
this past year.
RBMS, some lecture gave a talk
where she showed the numbers.
We were like, oh well that's
great because we've worked
at it for like 20 years.
And it move up one percent.
I mean she really,
she just showed it.
The whole room gasped.
There's something structural
that we need to sort of revisit.
How, what we are
imagining libraries do.
Or history departments,
or whatever field it is
that we might be
coming from to this.
Yeah.
>> I won't ask the
last question.
We have time for one more.
So how do you, how do
you encounter the ways
in which sort of pick?
Pitch our whole presence
within the printing history
has suppressed our imagination
around how we engage
with books and texts?
And I'm thinking here of sort
of analogous relationship
between medicine and
midwifery, right?
I'm thinking the
ways in which gender,
sort of [inaudible] practice as
I've found in my own research,
has been very gendered.
I'm always seeing the image of a
fortune-teller as a, as a woman.
And often a woman of color.
So how do you think
that sort of plays in?
Not just in, in the
form of exclusion.
But active suppression
around what we conceptualize
the book to be?
>> Oh, that's such
a good question.
Well, where I, where I see it.
This in part goes
back a little bit to,
to Matt's question earlier.
Is the ways in which
scholars describe
and acknowledged the work of
librarians and archivists.
Around what they do.
So it happened again recently.
It happens, you know with
pretty regularly, somebody.
There's some article somewhere.
And it says, "So-and-so
discovered this new thing!"
And you look into it you're
like well yeah, he discovered it
because the archivist
produced a finding aid,
and then you looked it up.
Like that's not really
discovery.
That's following a path.
And good for you that you know
how to walk in a straight line.
[Laughter] But I think
that there is something,
there is something
gendered about that.
The ways in which librarians
and archivists don't
get acknowledged.
So if the, the standard
thing, if you, right?
Like I came, I got my
PhD a long time ago.
I trained to be a
theater professor.
Like, like I've spent
a lot of time waiting
for acknowledgements
in books right?
Probably a lot of us have
and you do the sort of,
"Thank you to the Folger
Shakespeare Library
for funding me.
And thank you to the Huntington,
thank you to whoever."
And you might name
Richard [inaudible].
That was so many, that
was so, so long ago.
You might name like
the head librarian.
You might name you know for
sort of like helping you.
You might name the curator
for helping you understand
your things.
But do you, and then there might
be a time that's sort of like,
"And the registrar was
always so friendly to me.
The person who welcomed
me in every day."
>> Yeah, now that
you mention it, yeah.
>> But do, but do
people thank the-- never!
>> I thank you by
name in my book.
>> You and all the, all
the central library staff
in the Folger.
Look it up.
It says right there.
Because I was, because
this is, it's a thing.
We can't find those book if they
haven't been bought by the folks
at acquisitions, if
they haven't been worked
with by the curators.
If they haven't been
catalogued by the cataloguers.
We can't do that.
And whether those people
are male or female,
the profession is
gendered female.
It's that where I see--
and I see the same
thing happening with,
with digitization.
In which we think of that
as being a male field.
But nobody, nobody.
You look, you look to
see digital images,
digital facsimiles of books.
We're going to talk about this
later this summer when Dustin
and I do our panel together.
Who's, who took the pictures?
Who the -- knows?
If it was outsourced
to [inaudible] people,
you might see some [inaudible].
But you don't see names.
Even if it's inhouse.
Even if it's, I just
talked with the Folger
because I know it so well.
Even if it's at the Folger which
has this very, for a long time.
Super careful photography
and imaging lab.
Very, like super-carefully
professionally carefully
slowly done.
You might know the name
of the head of that lab.
But you don't know
[inaudible] included in that.
And definitely the people
who are taking the pictures
aren't included in that.
So there's also suppression
there, that kind of labor.
>> Turn that around and
explain why they should be.
>> Why they should be there?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, so that we know
who printed the books
in early modern France
or early modern London.
>> We know the publisher
or the print owner,
but we don't know
the names necessarily
of the type setters
and the, you know.
>> So in, in the
stationers' company,
if it's in London,
you can go back.
I mean, you can find who's
been apprentice to him.
You can, you can maybe
have a hope of recreating.
You're right that we don't
always know the names
underneath it.
But is the process sort
of tracing that through.
Just like those, so
I've got two answers.
Just like any compositor.
Or you know like
this is compositor E
who was always drunk and
didn't know what he was doing.
And he misspelled
everything in the first folio
because he was an idiot.
What they so has an impact
on what we [inaudible].
And so maybe we want
to have a part of that.
But I would also say that.
Libraries like to imagine
that they are bastions of-- .
Good, ethical decisions.
I can't think of what the
word is that I'm looking for.
Like, like what, libraries and
librarians are magically good!
Is the thing that
drives me nuts.
They're just inherently
fabulous people who understand,
who are always on the
right side of history.
Which is of course idiotic.
Because we're just people.
But there is part of
a way in which I think
if we are tasking
people to do that work.
That their work should
be acknowledged.
And it can either
be acknowledged
through decent money.
Or you can get credit
to your name.
We don't have the money.
And I would also, what does it,
what does it cost us to sort
of like add that information?
We're not talking pages
and pages of paper
that we have to pay for.
And the cost of paper
today is going up.
And it's a huge problem for
people who are publishing today.
It's like, it adds nothing
to the file size of an image.
I guess is what I'm
going to go with.
So why not?
[ Inaudible ]
[ Applause ]